non c'est pas ça c'est que toutes les
interventions qu'on fait pour l'instant
ne sont pas chers amis chers ennemis
nous passons maintenant au top chaud et
j'accueille pour apporter la
contradiction elizabeth teissier paco
rabanne j'accueille philippe starck a du
cnrs et alain gillot-pétré
m
alors fait pas bonne avait valu il va
bien ça on va finir mais ils veulent pas
s'arrêter aux jets de lave de santé dit
je veux bien que monsieur je le paie
très n'a aucune compétence
il va sortir le côté vraiment ça ça va
être monstrueux
alors ça c'est parce que j'aime beaucoup
parce je le vois halal par exemple le
brésil présente la météo et des supers
oui et c'est un homme mais lorsqu'il
parle de céder 6 tc phénomène là il est
trop rigoriste
on sait qu'on est assez bête pour nous
on est là pour répondre parce que je
sais exactement ce qu'il va dire moi
parce que c'est alors qu'elle colle fait
demain dimanche
j'ai levé très bon soir nul alors nous
ne tenons rien en série et airbags de
nous dire que la météo dans trois jeux
du deuxième majax soir était la même
chose bon écoute et on va voir
en tous les cas donc j'accueille
philippe starck amont soit rose et un
honnête homme vous êtes chargé de cette
unité
vous êtes chargé de vous êtes chargé de
recherche au cnrs oui au département de
la recherche spatiale
un printemps de paris à l'observatoire
de paris et alain gillot-pétré
évidemment on le présente plus puisqu'il
représente tous les sens alors je ne
comprends pas dans votre exposé là dans
cette confrontation c'est que vous
assimilez mais dirait mon travail et ma
démarche professionnelle à celle de paco
que j'aime beaucoup
à la mi mars à lui tout seul j'aimerais
apporter la contradiction qu'il appelle
et astrologue elizabeth teissier tous
d'accord à bâle
j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans attendez
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que paco rabanne
avait des flashs comme celui qui vous a
raconté jeu sur les gens qui jette dans
la seine et que vous en avez un peu là
vous interprétiez et oui al culié à
partir des astres oui donc j'ai bien
fait différent c'est une autre façon de
travailler
donc voilà maintenant quand j la
contradiction parce qu'ils se trouvent
et qui manquait à tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord avec vous alors justement
je me tourne vers vous pour commencer
philips zarka est-ce que alors oui enfin
bon là on va commencer par cas pourquoi
gillot pétré question de ça je rentre
ici je me fais agresser agressive je
suis pas marié pas dit un mot que je me
fais déjà insulté je tiendrais avec vous
sur un plateau c'est pour ça je suis
passé les souvenirs de mes chers paco
rabanne je me souviens pas d'avoir si
monsieur paco rabanne moi je n'ai
absolument rien contre vous ni ce que
vous prétendez pourquoi parce que vous
faites de la divination
vous avez parfaitement le droit monsieur
d'avoir des flashs moi aussi il m'est
arrivé d'avoir des flashs ce sont des
production d'hormones dans le cerveau
qui font qu'à un moment donné on voit
quelque chose c'est tout à fait c'est
tout à fait rationnel c'est pas la peine
de faire ça madame non et je vais
pédaler dans les jours à venir quand
même s'y attendait
ennuyé je vous demande pardon données
excusé de la façon dont vous l'avait
accueilli oui j'y vais demain je vous ai
je vous remercie monsieur de votre
honnêteté douala propres moyens mais
voilà je vous ai écouté je me suis dit
voilà un monsieur charmant qui est qu'à
des individus des trucs de divination
on verra bien on verra bien ce qui va se
passer mais vous ne deviez vous traduire
ce que vous je vous demande humblement
pardon de vous avoir agressé un si c'est
simplement d'un mauvais souvenir d'un
ancien plateau nous habille été très
violent et que vous avez dit de tous les
phénomènes de voyance foutaise
et ça ça m'avait vraiment à l'époque un
peu choqué bien parce que les drogues et
la madame quant à me contacter ou
elisabeth et ses je n'ai rien contre
vous d'abord je vous trouve ou non mais
je vous trouve très belle l'homme était
en encore très brillante et là dans
votre domaine vous êtes une star c'est
vrai vous êtes une star des femmes et
les droits en tant que personne à mon
profond respect très petit mais
maintenant cela dit je suis contre
l'astrologie et y avait le droit j'ai
parfaitement le droit tout alors si je
dis quelque chose
soyez gentils ne malgré ses pas dès que
je dis un mot en faisant en toc toc
comme vous avez fait tout à l'heure mais
attendez je veux bien me faire insulter
mais au moins fait d'eux oralement avec
des arcs je voudrais présenter mes
excuses très bien d'accorder évasion
massive à l'épée qui présentait vrai nom
j'ai pas bomber teacher
je vous ai vu faire tête d'armand à
sibiti mais c'est parce que parce que
c'est une vision tellement matérialiste
il rappelle le 19e siècle et qui
rappelle condillac en disait que le
cerveau produit sécrète la pensée me
comprenez on a dépassé ça depuis très
allantes une oreille droit d'aller à
toutankhamon et 8 du 19e siècle bon
klinsmann alors maintenant gérer points
dépassé sa mère d'enfant on a dépassé ça
nous on n'a rien proposé de mieux que je
sache
philippe arcade donc vous êtes au
courant de la faire il a vraiment
l'accès de nos scientifiques ont bien
été joueur de boules illzach cas sur le
plan alors vous vous êtes donc comme je
les dis chargé de recherche au cnrs est
ce que est ce que par exemple pour
reprendre ce que dit paco rabanne est ce
que les interférences magnétiques qui
vont se produire lors de l'éclipsé est
ce que ça peut déclencher des choses
concernant par exemple à la station
orbitale mir qui nous tomberait dessus
alors damman une chose à dire c'est que
effectivement je suis d'accord avec
alain gillot-pétré c'est j'ai beaucoup
moins de choses à dire par rapport à ce
que dit paco rabanne qui est voyant donc
c'est un peu de la magie
donc la science a pas grand chose à dire
dessus j'ai plus à dire par rapport à ce
que dit les maîtres tessier puisque elle
se fonde elle prétend que l'astrologie
celle des prévisions et a causé les
prédictions culot j'ai quand même le
culot mon taf a lieu de prétendre aimer
les choses arrivent
j'aurais même trois mares volet du nom
n'a pas du tout mais moi j'ai absolument
rien contre vous personnellement
alors donc bon j'ai rien à dire sur la
voyance en tant que tel par contre on
peut relever bon peut-être à l'aide de
l'information scientifique toutes les
incohérences les contre-vérités qui a
dans le livre de paco rabanne comme dans
celui de d'elisabeth tessier alors dans
l'astrologie en plus si l amalgame avec
la science donc ce n'est pas dans le cas
de la chorale alors ça sert donc
scientifique
maintenant il ya aussi en tant que
citoyen simplement enfin entendre que
personne moi là vraiment je m'oppose au
contenu de ces deux livres parce que je
trouve qu'on pourra développer mais en
gros que les deux personnes qui écrivent
prennent les gens pour des crétins
et ça ça me gêne ressentie ça c'est tout
non j'aime ça traîne les gens pour les
crises a dit quand le tzen travaillé
pour celle ci
moi je respecte les gens parce que je
les apporte j'aime les gens de 2,2 de
cette humanité et c'est pour prévenir
d'un danger possible
je ne vais pas me lancer pour des cons
mais vous êtes peut-être sincère j'ai
pas besoin de marquer pour sa part m
c'est ça en parlant comme je parle là je
détruis ma réputation je pense par
exemple tape sur les cuisses trouve à
une première question et n'a rien à voir
avec la science et de moins puisque vous
commencez à dire vous avez beaucoup
hésité pour y revoir et c'est pourquoi
vous avez une pub si vous n'êtes pas un
économiquement faibles pourquoi vous
êtes et ce que vous avez pas vous avez
fait un livre à 100 francs pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez pas fait des
campagnes d'affichage publicitaire des
choses comme ça parle par les ans mais
dit je suis en contrat avec lui alors
les uns et les autres si ce que je salue
une information ce que je fais de mon
fric ne vous intéresse pas vraiment vous
dire il aurait venir les gens je suis au
rouge dans mon compte en banque
stephen donc c'est bon mais j'ai pas
vaudois besoin de vous dire ça je ne
possède rien ni château ni maison ni
appartement à paris
il manquera ma propre affaire qui
m'appartient pas ni de voiture je
conduis pas ramassées dans la danse
simplement je fais minable
moi vous savez vous êtes scientifique
je n'ai aucun respect pour vous parce
que quand est ce qu a sagement dic n'est
que le noyage de ceux de tchernobyl
s'arrête à la frontière française
parce qu'il n'avait pas de visa alors je
me tape sur les cuisses et je dis
qu'est-ce que cette science tu sais pas
que un courant d'air breizh ou choix
mais vous ne pouvez pas assimiler ce que
dit une personne le centre scientifique
de l'époque en aux scientifiques en
général au plus grand soit fait que
d'abord on verra quoi largement réélu
qui a dit ça en plus il ya une volonté
politique derrière un vrai style yang ne
ne plie pas la tête devant la police des
polices celui là à faire c'est de vous
dire j'ai juste de vous dire un truc
parce qu'elle toute la carrière vous
avez d'ailleurs vous tout s'est tous ces
costumes tous les parfums tout ce qui
existe sous l'étiquette sous le nom de
paco rabanne que vos comptes en banque
soit en rouge
croyez moi vous n'êtes pas prévoyant je
suis pas fourmies je suis cigale c'est
vrai c'est vrai que paco van 3000 tonnes
enfin sous votre marque vante 3000
tonnes de cosmétiques par an alors alors
philippe starck a expliqué maintenant
dites nous pourquoi ces c'est possible
pas possible moi j'aimerai savoir le la
station mir là sont de ligue 1 qu'est ce
qui va se passer il ya 15 jours est
tombé à soyouz en argentine nuit
effectivement alors ce que ce que paco
rabanne a dit en fait n'est pas du tout
impossible dans le sens la probabilité
n'est pas zéro simplement que ça se
produise
et en plus ce que ça se produise au lieu
et à la date et à l'heure où il a dit ça
les chances sont extrêmement faibles je
sais pas si on peut les calculer mais
c'est peut-être une sur un million sur
un milliard se dire que c'est
certainement moins de chance que de se
faire écraser en sortant dans la rue
et pour arriver alors bon donc je ne dis
pas que c'est impossible
notre les chances scientifique à une
prédiction ça n'a rien à voir non plus s
scientifique il est qu'il ya une chance
sur 1 mais sa saisine et bilski dit
qu'est ce qui dit oui là je veux dire
j'ai pas fait
franchement on se doute bien que ce
qu'ils disent et puisque c'est une
prédiction ils se basent pas sur des
canons mais il se fonde sur une vision
et ça c'est le côté voyance ensuite il a
été ensuite il a été interprété sa
vision alors notamment il a été
interprété avec l'acca de l'e411 de
nostradamus or comme l'a dit fort
justement elizabeth teissier ya une
laisse et 80 sont très obscur et 1 942
mais la vôtre aussi
c'est arbitraire cher monsieur parce que
vous les théories de scientifiques vous
accueillir aujourd'hui demain votre
totalement comprendre grand nombre
contre contredite
parce que moi je suis juste une affaire
était justement la fierté les
scientifiques que de ne pas énoncer des
voûtes dit mais nous les vieux débats
des dom et des finalités qui permettent
d'être l'amour divin génial je te faire
me tromper c'est une éventualité le nom
est vaincue et des huit noms bon alors
ça c'est la manière à donner à ce que
philippe jacot a expliqué parce qu'on en
vient à nouveau bien je vais essayer
d'être rapide voile alors effectivement
d'abord paco rabanne dit si j'ai tort
c'est que j'aurais eu raison en fait
c'est grâce à ce qu'eux mêmes et c'est
que en gros grâce je sens que je viens
d'en avaler c'est le parlement met
d'accord à ma vessie le déchet ça il
faudrait compter les autres n'ont pas ce
qu'il dit et c'est ensuite jésuitique il
va dire ça il fera ça je déteste qu'on
puisse le ca moi dans mon bouquin jeudi
c'est une éventualité si ça n'arrive pas
je ferme ma gueule n'a jamais parce
qu'un seul aura prier ou etc ça continue
on est content
la soirée d'hier voilà c'est parce que
j'ai prévu non stop
ces groupes qui parlait après moi je
répondrai allez-y d'abord il faudra
casser très peu alors la station mir
fait un tour de la terre en une heure et
demie en gros si elle descend
régulièrement à cause de la friction de
la société toi elle descend
régulièrement à cause de l'atmosphère et
donc on la repousse régulièrement pour
la remontée alors évidemment ça coûte de
l'argent
la russie a des problèmes ça tout le
monde le sait donc il ya des problèmes
la terre tourne en dessous donc la
probabilité que ça tombe exactement un
endroit en un point donné jeudi est très
très faible
alors maintenant si ça tombe et ses
suppôts de satan qu'est-ce qui se
passerait alors j'ai fait un petit
calcul pour m'amuser on connaît la masse
de la station mir ses 120 tonnes dont
140 on connaît sa vitesse aussi si ça
tombe ça fait à peu près 10 puissance 12
joule bon c'est une secte unité
d'énergie
c'est de l'ordre de la dizaine de fois
la bombe d'hiroshima ouais sans les
radiations
ainsi que si elle tombe c'est juste que
c'est juste le souffle d'accord donc
alexa ont détruit pas paris on réalise
pas ce qu'il ya dans le premier chapitre
de votre livre
alex wiens du dioxyde de plutonium à
l'intérêt alors ça c'est la deuxième
chose ça c'est la deuxième chose permis
s'il est apte à petit a personnellement
quand même personnel ou 13,4 un titre
celui de tout bon mais encore il fallait
attendre des sanctions suite ou bon
invité jacques reviens ils sont devenus
fous visible continuer alors une
maintenant le problème c'est qu est ce
que ça contient alors moi
personnellement j'en sais rien
exactement qui est qui et une pile avec
du dioxyde de plutonium dedans comme il
y en a dans la plupart des sondes
spatiales qui ont été lancés c'est
possible
c'est une ce n'est néanmoins pas sûr
parce que on met des piles au dioxyde de
plutonium pour les sondes spatiales qui
vont très loin de la terre est très loin
du soleil celle d'olivier hinse cassimir
là par exemple mais comme voyageurs en
avait comme galileo en avait parce
qu'elles ne peuvent pas se servir de
panneaux solaires elles sont trop loin
du soleil d'accord c'est pour ça qu'il
entoure la terre dont c'est le test il a
des grands panneaux solaires peut-être
pas suffi il ya peut-être du dioxyde de
plutonium je ne le sais pas prétendre
ensuite qui a une ogive nucléaire dessus
voilà ça devient carrément gros c'est un
vision que j'ai non mais d'accord enfin
vous en parlait comme d'une hypothèse
page 106 de votre bouquin à partir de la
page 107 c'est une certitude
évidemment s'il ya une vision oui
d'accord donc
chercheur du cnrs jeudi à du plutonium
dedans oui je le suis dit c'est pas la
même chose c'est pas une ogive moi je
vais peut-être du dioxyde de plus vous
avez vu une logique moi je pense que
comme il ya sept américains qui ont été
récemment sur mini one hand il y aurait
eu du mal quand même
et ils ont caché la bombe dans un petit
coin c'est alors encore une fois c'est
possible mais tout ça est très
improbable
donc on rajoute de l'improbable à
l'improbable et ça donne même temps
n'existe pas si c'est eux c'est bien de
mon blabla polysémie regza ciel de plus
deux derniers combats se ravise un
problème c'est que ça tombe à l'endroit
du temps de monsieur brecht n'est finale
est pas s'amuser à lancer et à sa télé
tout ça pour le plaisir
c'est à l'époque tous les gestes de
l'urss c'était deux pour châtier le
grand ennemi est donc limité de la
guerre des étoiles a gardé plein de vols
d'allers retours
bon alors maintenant c'est clair mais
bon ça suffit
si on siffle parce que jésuites pas
exactement quand vous passez possible
c'est hallucinant vous êtes l'un des
frauds cucquois rivales à moteur à
l'aube est très élevé téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent qui ne pas comprendre
grand chose à ceux ci citons pèle bon
moi je dirai tout soleil pour toulouse
j'ai serré
nearly d'abord j'essaierai de dire tout
d'abord 1 999 après jésus-christ donc
après sa naissance
ils avaient l'an 2000 n'existait pas une
invention de passionnés des mouches
arabe en dessous du genre tu joues the
rescue les cieux je suis va lui sourire
vous allez vous allez sourire qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en 980 évier s'est passé
à lyon qu'on annonçait la fin du monde
c'est pas vrai si nous sommes à finir
monsieur gravats ne soyez pas rater ça
j'ai étudié sa hausse hier à des amis
archives i messieurs on annonçait la fin
du monde qui commencerait par un déluge
et leur chevet de lions voyons que sa
pose et du trouble dans les esprits et
monte en chaire dans la cathédrale de
lyon et à dix après avoir interrogé le
très haut
la date de la fin du monde est reporté à
une date ultérieure
ça ne m'est rien
ok parce que ça a été inventé la fin
l'accord du miel à dix et un ter a opté
au 19e siècle par les romantiques
créneau d'agen mes amis rejettent ont
été des ça il n'y a jamais eu de père en
2000 d'abord pour une simple raison de
l'ambiance de la mairie qu'elle n'ait
pas besoin était complètement illettrés
qui n'avait aucune
il savait uniquement qu'ils étaient sous
le règne de tels roi il savait même pas
ni le jour ni l'heure où il était et ça
c'est faux et ça c'est de la vision des
ddd des gens du 19e sur la passion pour
ce que mépris des gens du moyen-âge qui
était plus cultivé et plus éclairés que
les gens d'aujourd'hui car le moyen-âge
est aujourd'hui monsieur tu le paies
très ne vous énervez pas content si tu
passes mais je suis passé j'ai le feu à
l'intérieur et moi ce soir avec la
vision une nouvelle le feu
et ben ali avant ma part tout bon
contenu comme on vient de me trouver
non mais attendez
voilà la tension dans les années qui
viennent tous ici nous aurons des
problèmes d'argent
oui nous aurons laissez moi finir je
vous en prie nous avons des problèmes
personnels de santé nous aurons d'épaulé
avec le patron nous aurons des problèmes
de goulots en un moment pas au même
moment peut-être mais de toute façon on
n'annonce rien qui ne soit prédictible
l'astrologie est en fait la possibilité
pour certaines personnes d'annoncer aux
autres ce qui ne peut pas ne pas leur
arrivée le cas ici et c'était l'idée que
je voulais me dit c'est l'idée que je
voulais vous dire madame et que si ça
fait du bien à certaines personnes
et bien si c'est une psychothérapie je
suis relativement pour parce que c'est
effectivement les affaires du berlaymont
maintenant d'un point de vue
scientifique
ça n'existe voyez vous madame vous une
grande différence qui entre vous et nous
pas monsieur rabanne
c'est que vous vous défendez votre big
stack mais nous le défendons la vérité
mais nous c'est gratuit c'est au lycée
ça elle est végétarienne en plus
certains hameaux pour finir la prévision
d'elisabeth tessier à propos de cassini
même si c'est possible et encore plus
fausse que dax a écrit donc vous seront
un peu dire pour conclure c'est quand
même le but de le ben oui mais à taux
mais j'ai fait une erreur d'une semaine
dans la date est passée près de la terre
le 18 août pas le 11
vous avez écrit le 11 vous avez écrit le
11 bon merci à tous alors ils vont le